hi welcome to this video my name is
grace Helbig if you do not know people
say I don't use inflection correctly now
because of my insatiable thirst for
lemonade I have decided to cook
something with the Beyonce's lemonade
theme not the theme of lemonade because
there are so many things that it is so
complex as an art piece and ah instead
of air basically wanted to make some
sort of food that had lemon in it so I
went on Pinterest and I found a recipe
for parmesan you couldn't even get more
than one word up the title
okay just like on recipe for some sort
of parmesan lemon shrimp angel hair
pasta dish that looked amazing and I'm
gonna make it more amazing by plating it
in a very special way and what way is
that need to wait and find out and I
don't even know what's gonna work it's
just an idea in my head I haven't ever
tried before so we'll see so today I'm
gonna cook for you a baguette big
baguette be spaghett Bay but get me some
lemonade but get be some lemonade's it
doesn't change your gums totally as if
you say slightly different than before
here's what you need to make this dish I
also decided that not only am I going to
make this dish for you I am going to
regale you with facts that I think could
be true about Beyonce enjoy first thing
we did was cook our angel hair pasta
some might call it beyonce hair pasta
that was a nice way to intro that
ingredient we got to boil some salt
water and put the faucet oh sorry go you
shouldn't be standing under something
that I can potentially wrap up I don't
know Beyonce called sea salt sea salt
now we're going to let the water boil
and want to some boiling we're gonna put
our pasta in
what does boils let's cook our shrimp
beyond cycles shrimp tiny be on face
book scrimp you smell like not Beyonce
we're going to put some olive oil and
some butter 3 tablespoons of unsalted
butter into the pan
Beyonce called unsalted butter desalted
Beyonce utter freedom oh yes this is not
a healthy dish but you know what else is
in a healthy dish rejection based on
infidelity oh I got cut garlic jack
dammit I need three cloves of garlic
mince I bet
Beyonce smells like garlic another one
thinks that's great the anti called
garlic cloves garlic Knowles chop chop
chop chop chop we're going to add our
shrimp to this pan of butter and oil
I shouldn't have already been undressed
don't say I don't show you nudes on this
channel so Beyonce learn to dance strip
in gonna sauté the shrimp for two
minutes then we're going to add the
garlic
after that Wow okay
I'll wash your hands let that water
heats up born and turn the shrimp over
when Beyonce cooks she doesn't call
cooking she calls it Beyonce on an
edible oh okay let's put our pasta in
and that friends oh no you couldn't
handle it I'm you're gonna do a fire oh
no oh my god ah what do I do
I definitely keep the camera rolling
they're so embarrassing Beyonce's gonna
see this yeah everything's fine
I've reached the forgiveness stage what
happens with the shrimp down like a
season with salt and pepper travel
that's hurt me be so be on side cross
pepper pepper then we put the garlic in
oh thank God I to Target and bought this
chop and scoop knife so that I could
chop and scoop all my garlic into my pan
damn you smell like be on a sec any that
your pasta cook oh boy Wow everyone this
is embarrassing for you Oh
oh boy perfect yeah we're trying to keep
way down low on the shrimp get out of
here old pasta that's Beyonce's nickname
for jay-z yeah well we need 1/2
teaspoons of lemon I went and bought
this fancy lemon juicer and these lemons
and we're gonna do some okay Wow
get all the way down in the lemon and
then we're going to hold on to these
empty lemon rinds first I don't know a
surprise we're gonna plate them inside
the lemons Oh pasta you're getting hot
and bothered
you're like Becky with the good hair
you're probably hot and you bother a lot
of people just need to chop up three
tablespoons of parsley and three
tablespoons of basil let's do that this
parsing ru parser cilantro you might be
skew cilantro
that's like meeting so launched and
thinking it's beautiful I mean you see
that I got classes done so we are going
to do to it what jay-z did to he and
Beyonce's relationship strain it yes
trainer we I suppose reserve some of the
pasta water it's okay because my balls
full now we toss this in with our shrimp
oh boy okay just like jay-z's humility
this overfloweth supposed to put 1/3 cup
of reserved pasta water in with this but
let's just toss this in see how it goes
it might just put regular water it was
it the a site called regular water Kelly
Rowland okay okay and you're kind of
doing I need three tablespoons of fresh
lemon juice 1/2 the
I'll say and then we also need a couple
tablespoons of parsley and basil athlete
chop it like that they did with jazzy
testicles got some parsley in there I'm
going chef basil oh are you coming from
my copyright claims okay basil in I also
need to put some Parmesan cheese and 1/2
cup of shredded Parmesan and we put the
parmesan in and now we toss it and
that's about it you're done except we're
going to place this in a really cute way
what a mess Ted Beyonce when she finally
had a chance to reflect on her marriage
let me clean up for a second
beer about me okay we're back things are
clean things are cute I went to Target
and i unnecessarily bought this serving
planner for this video but really for my
life but i justified it by saying this
was a reveal
that's also what Beyonce did turn your
pain into arts Fanta called art Beyonce
okay so we're going to take our hollow
lemon halves and we're going to put some
of our pasta in each one to make tiny
servings of our lemon pasta parmesan
things look whoa okay oh my god this is
gorgeous
that was actually an audio recording of
Fanta giving birth oh my god this is so
good yeah
it's what the aunts they say when Jacy
was apologizing and there you have it
your spaghetti some what oh you have a
spaghetti
hey hey rabbit you had first forgive me
a lemon aid because these aid you in
your hunger game that's a difference but
look how cute oh my god you just eat the
Rose 11 and you hardly have any left
over thank you guys so much for watching
this video if you liked this video give
it a thumbs up if you want me to cook
other things in the future
leave some suggestions in the comments
below and don't forget to subscribe
because beyonce is already
it said every artist forever
I don't know I'm eating one that's what
Beyonce said when she actually had twins
look it they make a perfect fight did
you very good as a bandage have four
seven digits have good job posture just
good always by the way I'll leave a link
for the recipe they've gone on Pinterest
in description box below ever enters
them who following it Ashley I make
lemons out of lemonade what